sagement enfouis depuis 80 ans dans le
lit de la Loire une bombe de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale va donc être retirée
l'opération délicate doit avoir lieu
demain à Saint-Cyr-sur-Loire ou l'engin
explosif a été découvert et pour éviter
toute accident les riverains ont été
prier d'évacuer les explications avec
Sébastien Branger
les barrières sont déjà en place ainsi
que quelques panneaux d'interdiction de
stationner à partir de mardi 9h il sera
interdit de circuler en voiture à vélo
ou même à pied entre le pont Napoléon et
le pont Saint-Côme sur le quai de
Saint-Cyr et celui des maisons blanches
c'est à la hauteur de ce dernier
qu'auront lieu les opérations de
déminage d'une bombe datant de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale qui vit quelque
part dans la Loire étant donné la
proximité des habitations les résidences
situées dans la zone de sécurité vont
être évacués durant l'opération une zone
d'accueil est prévue dans l'ancienne
mairie de Saint-Cyr-sur-Loire pour ceux
qui ne pourront pas trouver refuge
d'autres se débrouilleront par leur
propre moyen
juste derrière donc ce que je vais faire
c'est que je vais aller directement chez
mes parents parce que j'ai un chien avec
moi et vu que personne ne peut rester
dans les lieux je vais pas laisser mon
chien donc j'ai pas d'autre choix que
d'aller chez ma mère vous êtes pas trop
inquiète
non si les meubles explosent c'est quand
même dommage parce que avec
l'appartement je suis quand même
locataire donc ça serait dommage que des
désagréments mais je pense pas si nous
ont prévenu suffisamment l'avance je
pense que ça devrait aller l'opération
de déminage devrait se terminer aux
alentours de 14 heures